today's video is sponsored by short form
you don't have time to read every book
ever written and that's where short form
comes in you guys can get a five day
trial to their times saving book guides
more on them in a bit
we talked a lot about the ancient
empires that were centered thousands of
years ago in that cradle of civilization
known as mesopotamia we've talked about
the acadians the babylonians the
persians and today we're going to take a
look at the assyrians specifically we're
going to examine the life of ashubanapol
arguably the greatest king of assyria he
held dominion over the neo-assyrian
empire which in his time was the most
far-reaching empire in history while its
capital nuneva was probably the largest
richest and most magnificent city in the
ancient world ashabanapal is best
remembered for his royal library which
had amassed a gigantic collection unlike
any before it thanks to the king's
zealous hoarding of texts but make no
mistake ashabanapol was a ruthless and
bloodthirsty warmonger one the likes of
whom the world had seldom seen up to
that point he transformed his mighty
assyrian army into a war machine that
mercilessly stomped his enemies into
submission the egyptians the babylonians
the alamites the simerians the arabs
they all faced the wrath of ashabanapal
[Music]
born circa 685 bc bashabana paul was the
son of esherhaden king of the neo-syrian
empire and one of his royal wives
perhaps ashara hamad the only one whose
name we know ashabanapol was part of the
sargoni dynasty of assyria which ended
up being the empire's last dynasty
before its complete collapse but also
represented assyria at the height of its
power between approximately 2000 bc and
500 bc mesopotamia was dominated by two
cultures the assyrians and the
babylonians who ostensibly took turns in
being the regional hegemon
ashurbanipal's great-grandfather sargon
ii founded the sargani dynasty by
usurping throne from his predecessor in
722 bc and ushering in one final golden
age for assyria he was succeeded by
senate cherub in 705 bc who grew his
empire's power even further and
unleashed utter destruction on his
kingdom's arch-enemy babylon leaving the
city in ruins following a brutal siege
and sacking however his biggest
contribution was moving his empire's
capital to the city of nineveh and
undertaking massive construction
projects to transform it into the envy
of the ancient world after him came
ashabanapal's father esha haddan in 681
bc even though he was sent a cherub's
son he distanced himself from his father
both in texts and in
he considered that it would be better to
appease the babylonians rather than rule
them through fear and violence so one of
his most ambitious projects was to
rebuild what sennacherib had destroyed
eshe haddon restored all of babylon's
important buildings and structures and
even took part in religious ceremonies
honoring the babylonian gods such as
marduk that being said echehaden wasn't
completely peaceful and although he
showed a lot of favor to babylon that
did not extend to other vassal states
such as saigon and iratu which tried to
rebel before being once again dominated
by the assyrian army eshehaden also
attacked new lands most notable of all
being egypt which he conquered in 671 bc
the assyrian drove out the reigning
pharaoh and became the first
mesopotamian ruler to give himself the
title king of egypt esha haddan had a
large family and ashurbanipal was
probably his fourth eldest son nobody
expected him to ascend to the throne
which is why he most likely trained as a
scribe or a priest when he was young
however escher hadn't had been a sickly
man throughout his life and so were many
of his children his eldest son and crown
prince died unexpectedly around 672 bc
so esta haddon was left with a task of
deciding which offspring would become
the new ruler he decided that there
should be two kings the king of assyria
and the king of babylon although the two
were technically equal everybody knew
that the king of assyria was the true
ruler who governed the whole empire for
whatever reason ershaden dismissed his
third son as a candidate scholars
speculate that this was because the boy
was already in poor health so it was
assumed that he wouldn't live very long
that left the king with his second and
fourth oldest sons shamash
again we don't know what reasoning esha
hadn't had but he named ashabanapal as
his true successor while the older
brother was given the lesser title of
king of babylon afterwards he had all of
his vassals recognize ashabanapol as his
legitimate heir by issuing a decree
called the loyalty treaty of nakia
zakutu named after ashabanapal's
grandmother this came in handy because
esha haddon did not have a lot of time
left even though the king was already in
poor health he marched to fight the
egyptians in 669 bc who were rebelling
against a syrian rule he died on the way
but the steps that he took previously
ensured that the transition of power
went smoothly and each son accepted his
new role
at least for now
[Music]
in 668 bc ashabanapal became the ruler
of the neo-assyrian empire the largest
and most powerful empire that the world
had ever seen up to that point his
priority was to finish what his father
had started and bring egypt back under
his dominion the conquest of egypt was
not an easy one eschaton's first attempt
had been repelled and even when he had
been successful in sacking thieves in
671 bc he was unable to capture the
pharaoh tahako or tahara who fled to
kush now tahako was back and with
reinforcements and after occupying
memphis he forced all the local
officials to recognize him as pharaoh of
egypt again therefore in 667 bc
ashurbanipal marched on egypt to crush
the rebellion once and for all
fortunately for us ashurbanipal was an
incredibly thorough record keeper
archaeologists have recovered numerous
tablet cylinders reliefs and other
artifacts that were commissioned in his
time and
detail his exploits all of his successes
at least he wasn't as diligent when it
came to preserving his failures for
posterity anyway one of these artifacts
is known as the rasam cylinder and it
gives a long first-hand account of most
of his military campaigns so we might as
well find out how it happened from the
king of assyria himself he said in my
first campaign i marched against tahaka
king of egypt and ethiopia whom eshardon
king of assyria the father who begot me
had defeated and whose land he brought
under his sway this same tahaka forgot
the might of ashur ishtar and the other
great gods my lords and put his trust
upon his own power he turned against the
kings and regrets whom my own father had
appointed in egypt he entered and took
residence in memphis the city which my
own father had conquered and
incorporated into a syrian territory at
these deeds my heart became enraged my
soul cried out i raised my hands in
prayer to assure and the assyrian ishtar
i busted my mighty forces which assured
ishtar had placed in my hands against
egypt and ethiopia i directed the march
in the course of my march 22 kings of
the seacoast of the midst of the sea and
of the mainland servants subject to me
brought their rich presence before me
and kissed by feet those kings together
with their forces on their ships by sea
on the dry land with my armies i caused
to take path and road tarko king of
egypt and ethiopia heard of the advance
of my army in memphis and mustered his
fighting men against me offering armed
resistance in battle with the help of
the great gods my lords who advance at
my side i defeated his army in a battle
on the open plain tahako heard of the
defeat of his armies while in memphis
the terrible splendor of asur and ishtar
overcame him and he went mad the glory
of my majesty with which the gods of
heaven and earth have crowned me
overpowered him he forsook memphis and
fled to save his life to thebes that
city i seized i had my troops enter and
occupy it ashabanapal could be pretty
cruel even by ancient standards as
evidenced by the fate of the cities that
plotted against him and the people of
sais pinetti snoo and the rest of the
cities as many as had joined wisdom in
plotting evil they struck down with the
sword both great and small not a man
among them escaped their corpses they
hung on stakes they stripped off their
skins and covered the city walls with
them as for toharco he fled once again
and died in 664 bc ashabanapal then
installed naco the first as the new
ruler under his vassalage and went home
hoping that that would be the end of it
but it wasn't the end because tahago had
appointed a successor named tantamani or
tanwittamani and he also tried to retake
egypt prompting a second campaign from
the assyrians that very same year
ashabanapal was once again successful
and this time his actions were more
drastic and definitive ending the sack
of thebes in 663 bc a momentous event
that is even mentioned several times in
the bible he effectively ended the
nubian line of pharaohs and returned to
nineveh rich in plundering including
silver gold precious stones and all the
wealth of the palace rich cloth precious
linen great horses supervising men and
women two obelisks of splendid electrum
weighing 2
500 talents now we'll continue with
today's story in just a moment but first
a word from a brand new sponsor short
form if you like my channels then you
probably like learning stuff a lot of
you guys like to expose yourself to new
ideas or new information by reading
which is great but the last two decades
have seen an exponential rise in the
amount of content that's available for
consumption from youtube content like
this very video you're watching right
now to articles podcasts and of course
traditional books if you're like me you
probably feel that there's never enough
time in the day to consume everything
that you think is interesting that's
where short form comes in they hijack
the central themes and need to know
ideas from hundreds of books making them
easily available to you in consumable
packages and this can be really
convenient too for instance you know
there's a massive 500 page tone that
you've been thinking about reading but
you're not sure if it's something you
want to invest all of your free time in
pop into short form check out the
summary and you'll have a much better
idea of whether or not it's worth your
time short form is also a great tool for
books you've already read listen to
their guides once a book is complete and
it can give you additional insight into
some of the major motifs or maybe you
read something a long time ago and you
want a little refresher either way it
won't be long before you're walking
around with the confidence of an english
lit major if you want a recommendation
today i'd recommend prisoners of
geography 10 maps that explain
everything about the world i don't want
to spoil anything it's an absolute
must-read do go check it out on short
form right now you guys can get a free
unlimited short form trial for five days
plus a discounted annual subscription
just go to shortform.com forward slash
biographics to check it out there's a
link below and back to today's video
despite his triumph in egypt
ashurbanipal's influence over the region
began decreasing almost immediately and
this time the king did little to stop
this part of the reason why was because
egypt was at the outskirts of his empire
so from a logistical standpoint it was a
lot of effort to march his army there
from nineveh another reason was that
ashubanapol had other revolts enemies
and projects to deal with so he did not
want to dedicate all of his time and
energy towards egypt inside of syria
ashby nepal had a lot of ambitious
construction plans especially in the
capital of nineveh during his time some
scholars believe that nunavut became the
largest city in the world with a
population of approximately a hundred
and twenty thousand people his
grandfather senate chariot had built a
massive opulent palace in the capital
which became known as the palace without
rival due to its grandeur not to be
outdone ashabanapal constructed his own
palace but also new temples to the gods
as well as city walls and gates which
were adorned with reliefs that even to
this day constitute some of the most
detailed and well-preserved examples of
assyrian art many of the reliefs show
ashabanapol engaged in lion hunting
which was not only considered the sport
of kings but also a symbol of a ruler's
ability to protect his people from
assyria's enemies but the walls and the
temples all paled in comparison with the
king's most ambitious project the royal
library of ashabanapol this may have
been the first great library in the
world older than the more famous library
of alexandria ashabanapol possessed a
thirst for knowledge almost like an
obsession the same way other kings would
crave jewels gold and other treasures
all the cities in his empire were
ordered to bring him copies of the most
important texts and tributes and he
sometimes even conquered new settlements
just to get his hands on their libraries
his reasoning was thus i ashibanapol
king of the universe on whom the gods
have bestowed intelligence i have placed
these tablets for the future in the
library of nineveh for my life and for
the well-being of my soul to sustain the
foundations of my royal name soon after
ashabanapal's death the library was
destroyed in a fire but this turned out
to be a real boon for archaeology most
of the text was written on clay tablets
and they didn't burn in the fire they
were actually hardened and then got
buried in the rubble they were
rediscovered during the mid 19th century
and since then over 30 000 tablets and
fragments have been recovered becoming
one of the greatest troves of
information about the ancient world
construction projects and scholarly
pursuits aside ashabanapol was still a
warmonger at heart and he remained
involved in one military conflict or
another for most of his reign again
going by the rat and cylinder after his
two campaigns in egypt ashabanapal
fought some of the other smaller
kingdoms that either tried to rebel or
provided aid to his enemies this
included tar and award to phoenician
states and the neo-hittite kingdoms
called tabal and hilaku he then sent aid
to king gaijis of lydia in his fight
against the sumerians and then invaded
the land of the manians however the
biggest conflict at this time was his
war with the elamites elam was a
civilization that settled north of the
persian gulf next to sumer occupying the
western part of modern-day iran it
remains to this day a preeminent yet
mysterious culture of the ancient world
preeminent because it was around for
over 2 600 years mysterious because
almost everything we know about them
comes from second-hand sources like the
acadian sumerians babylonians egyptians
and of course the assyrians the alabite
language seems to have developed in
isolation from its neighbors and has yet
to be fully deciphered one thing we do
know is that entered into direct
conflict with assyria in the late 8th
century bc during the reign of sargon ii
he was ashubanappal's great-grandfather
the two sides continued to fight during
the reigns of senecarab and eshehaden
but ashabanapal decided that he would
end the war once and for all by
annihilating the elamite civilization
this was a drawn-out affair that
occurred over two different campaigns
but once again we can let ashubanapul
himself tell us what happened like a
terrible hurricane i overwhelmed alarm
in its entirety i cut off the head of
tumen the king countless of their
warriors i slew with their corpses i
filled the plane about souza their blood
i let run down the ally it's water i
died red like wool although victorious
ash banapal had to end his first
campaign against alam in a hurry because
he received word that alliance of medes
simerians and persians took advantage of
his departure and launched a surprise
attack on nineveh therefore bashabanapo
returned to his capital and with the
help of his allies the scythians he
managed to repel the invaders in alarm
he installed a new king before leaving
but it didn't take long for the elamites
to rebel against him therefore in 647 bc
ashbanipal marched on alam again this
time he enacted widespread destruction
including raising the capital of susan
to the ground sousa the great holy city
abode of their gods seat of their
mysteries i conquered i entered its
palace as i opened their treasuries
where silver and gold goods and wealth
were amassed i destroyed the ziggurat of
susa i smashed its shining copper horns
i reduced the temples of elum to nought
their gods and goddesses i scattered to
the wind the tombs of their ancient and
recent kings i devastated i exposed to
the sun and i carried away their bones
towards the land of ashore i devastated
the provinces of alarm and on their
lands i sowed salt anyone of royal
alamite blood was made a slave most of
the population was relocated and the
cities and fields were left empty
ashabanapal thought that if he turned
alarm into a wasteland it would no
longer be a threat however because fate
can have a cruel sense of humor the
exact opposite happened the persians
took over that territory and slowly
began rebuilding it while also gaining
an important foothold in the region just
a few decades after alarm's destruction
assyria would fall as well
[Music]
that's still in the future though for
now ashabanapal had another problem to
contend with one that many regarded as
inevitable his brother shammush
to nobody's surprise he was never happy
that his father named his younger
brother as heir to his empire while he
received the inferior mostly ceremonial
title king of babylon for 16 years he
bided his time until he decided to
strike in 652 bc the civil war erupted
although it seems that shemashum okin's
goal was to achieve independence for
babylon and become its true king rather
than an attempt to usurp the throne of
the whole empire according to some
inscriptions he had been plotting
against his brother for years and had
conspired with alum against ash banapal
they weren't the only ones either as
once the war started shamash
kin found plenty of other allies willing
to fight on its side to gain
independence for their kingdoms this
included the arameans the chaldeans and
the kingdoms of gutien and muru even so
it seems like the strength of this
coalition was no match for assyria
although as they say history is written
by the pictures and in this case we only
have ashurbanipal's inscriptions to use
as a source unsurprisingly he is
presented as being nigh indestructible
thanks to the protection of asur and
ishtar i trod them underfoot to their
farthest border the yoke of a sewer
which they had cast off i placed upon
them revenues dues and first fruits for
the gods of assyria i imposed upon them
my royal tribute and tax yearly without
ceasing i laid upon them it seems that
most rebellion kingdoms got off pretty
easy especially since ashbaner paul had
a reputation of being exceedingly cruel
to his enemies however that was not also
the case for babylon the assyrian king
mounted a siege on the city that lasted
over two years driving the population
into starvation with one inscription
mentioning that the babylonians had to
resort to cannibalism by eating the
flesh of their sons and daughters to
stay alive when the city finally fell in
648 b.c
mckinnon committed suicide by fire as
for the rest of the sinners as
ashabadopoul called them this was their
fate as for those men and their vulgar
males who uttered vulgarity against
assure my god and plotted evil against
me i slit their mouths and brought them
low the rest of the people alive by the
colossae between which had cut down sena
cherub the father of the father who
begot me at that time i cut down those
people there as an offering to his shade
their dismembered bodies i fed to the
dogs swine wolves and eagles to the
birds of heaven and the fish of the deep
ashabanapal's final military campaign
that we know of took place in the
arabian peninsula against the various
kingdoms that were situated there he
first took up the sword against a king
named uwait who is known only from this
inscription he was a former vassal who
allied himself with shamish shimokin
during the failed rebellion according to
the rasam cylinder ash banapal defeated
ouit in battle but he did not kill him
as he had a more humiliating punishment
in mind for him instead he placed the
former king in a kennel alongside dogs
and jackals so he would guard one of the
gates into nineveh afterwards
ashabanapal fought amaladi king of the
kuderites after the latter invaded a
kingdom that was under assyrian
protection again ash banipal was
triumphant and he stuck his enemy in a
dog kennel his final foes were two
brothers imu and rba who were the sons
of a king who also rebelled alongside
the babylonians they too were defeated
and taken prisoner and it seems that
abia died of thirst on his way to
nineveh while amu was flayed alive in
the assyrian capital ashbanipal also
conquered the cities of ushu and akka
massacring its people and capturing its
treasures for refusing to pay tribute to
him now we arrive at the mysterious end
of his reign which is full of guesswork
and debatable ideas due to a lack of
sources sometime around 630 bc
ashabanapal fell ill and traveled to the
city of haran in modern-day turkey at
that point he disappears from the
historical record so he was either
deposed or most likely he died there of
some unknown illness his son asha
atollani became the new king of the
neo-assyrian empire but he lacked the
strong will ruthlessness and
determination of his father and all of
assyria's vassals knew this and many
revolts occurred in the years that
followed the syrians the medes the
babylonians emerged as the greatest
threat to assyria as they banded
together to bring down the once mighty
war machine that had subjugated them all
the external strife might also have been
compounded by a civil war between asha
attiliani and his brother sin shah
ishkun who may have wanted the assyrian
throne for himself we know that the
first sibling only ruled for a few years
before being succeeded by sinsha ishkan
but we have no idea if asha ettalani
died or was usurped his brother had a
longer reign of approximately 15 years
but it mainly consisted of sinsha ishkan
desperately trying to hold on to his
crumbling empire ultimately he failed
and the once mighty capital of nineveh
fell in 612 bc thus marking the end of
the neo-assyrian empire and the start of
the neo-babylonian empire
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]